château du but où le charme de la
vieille pierre mise en valeur par un
travail d'entretien minutieux et pas un
des outils pratiques et ludiques pour
faire cette visite sur sur ce site on a
aussi ceux ci qui atteint audio peine ah
oui d'accord qu'on peut soit m enfoncé
les pratiques ou en anglais actifs
cette petite délégation vient de
l'hexagone elle est en repérage sur des
sites très divers pour une vue
d'ensemble du pays martinique choix qui
sera ensuite discuté entre
professionnels du tourisme ce qui se
passe c'est qu'on est en train de jour
non vraiment essayer d'avoir la vue la
plus complète possible que ce soit côté
cmt vraiment de du type de circuit de
l'offre qu'ils ont envie de mettre en
valeur sur toute l'île donc ça c'est ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui et demain
après-demain aussi on va regarder au
sein de notre communauté que ce soit
côté hébergement ou côté expériences les
plus beaux joyaux qu'on a envie de
montrer de cette île est en fait on va
composer ce voyage de presse dans l'est
dans les semaines qui viennent on va
réfléchir au meilleur parcours pour être
sûr la meilleure mise en valeur possible
de lille un repérage pour une délégation
de journalistes français et étrangers
qui doit venir en février airbnb en
martinique
est ce une nouvelle façon de proposer à
nouveau parc de logements et d
expérience unique celle idées pour
dynamiser ce secteur d'activité et la
réflexion porte désormais sur un
partenariat possible entre la plateforme
de réservation et le comité martiniquais
du tourisme